Independence is a very
useful property.
Whenever it is true, we can
break up complicated
situations into simpler ones.
In particular, we can do
separate calculations for each
piece of a given model and
then combine the results.
We're going to look at an
application of this idea into
the analysis of reliability of
a system that consists of
independent units.
So we have a system that
consists of a number, let's
say, n, of units.
And each one of the units
can be "up" or "down".
And it's going to be "up" with
a certain probability pi.
Furthermore, we will assume
that unit failures are
independent.
Intuitively, what we mean is
that failure of some of the
units does not the affect the
probability that some of the
other units will fail.
If we want to be more formal,
we might proceed as follows.
We could define an event
Ui to be the event that
the ith unit is "up".
And then make the assumption
that the events U1, U2, and so
on up to Un, if we have n
units, are independent.
Alternatively, we could define
events Fi, where event Fi is
the event that the ith unit is
down, or that it has failed.
And we could assume that the
events Fi are independent, but
we do not really need a
separate assumption.
As a consequence of the
assumption that the Ui's are
independent, one can argue
that the Fi's are also
independent.
How do we know that
this is the case?
If we were dealing with just two
units, then this is a fact
that we have already proved
a little earlier.
We did prove that if two events
are independent, then
their complements are
also independent.
Now that we're dealing with
multiple events here, a
general number n,
how do we argue?
One approach would be to be
formal and start from the
definition of independence
of the U events.
And that definition gives
us a number of formulas.
Then manipulate those formulas
to prove the conditions that
are required in order to check
that the events Fi are
independent.
This is certainly possible,
although it is a bit tedious.
However, the approach we will
be taking in situations like
this one is that we will use
the intuitive understanding
that we have of what
independence means.
So independence in this context
means that whether
some units are "up" or down,
does not change the
probabilities that some
of the other units
will be "up" or down.
And by taking that
interpretation, independence
of the events that units are
"up" is essentially the same
as independence of the
units [having]
failed.
So we take this implication for
granted and now we move to
do some calculations for
specific systems.
Consider a particular system
that consists of three
components.
And we will say that the system
is "up", if there
exists a path from the left to
the right that consists of
units that are "up".
So in this case, for the system
to be "up", we need all
three components to be "up"
and we proceed as follows.
The probability that the
system is "up"--
this is the event that the first
unit is "up", and the
second unit is "up", and
the third unit is "up".
And now we use independence to
argue that this is equal to
the probability that the first
unit is "up" times the
probability that the second
probability that the
third unit is "up".
And in the notation that we have
introduced this is just
p1 times p2 times p3.
Now, let us consider
a different system.
In this system, we will say
that the system is "up",
again, if there exists a path
from the left to the right
that consists of units
that are "up".
In this particular case the
system will be "up", as long
as at least one of those three
components are "up".
We would like again to calculate
the probability that
the system is "up".
And the system will be "up",
as long as either unit 1 is
"up", or unit 2 is "up",
or unit 3 is "up".
How do we continue from here?
We cannot use independence
readily, because independence
refers to probabilities of
intersections of events,
whereas here we have a union.
How do we turn a union
into an intersection?
This is what De Morgan's Laws
allow us to do, and involves
taking complements.
Instead of using formally De
Morgan's Laws, let's just
argue directly.
Let us look at this event.
That unit 1 fails, and unit
2 fails, and unit 3 fails.
What is the relation between
this event and the event that
we have here.
They're complements.
Why is that?
Either all units fail, which is
this event, or there exists
at least one unit,
which is "up".
So since this event is the
complement of that event, this
means that their probabilities
must add to 1, and therefore
we have this relation.
And now we're in better shape,
because we can use the
independence of the events F to
write this as 1 minus the
product of the probabilities
that each one
of the units fails.
And with the notation that we
have introduced using the
pi's, this is as follows.
The probability that unit
1 fails is 1 minus the
probability that it is "up".
Similarly, for the second unit,
1 minus the probability
that it is "up".
And the same for
the third unit.
So we have derived a formula
that tells us the reliability,
the probability that a system of
this kind is "up" in terms
of the probabilities of its
individual components.
You will have an opportunity to
deal with more examples of
this kind, a little more
complicated, in the problem
that follows.
And even more complicated, in
one of the problem-solving
videos that we will have
available for you.